I'm now seeing two therapists
just to compare no my current one was
like you know you should maybe think
about seeing someone who really
specializes in OCD oh and I went and saw
this woman once and uh we agreed to keep
going and I'm seeing her again this week
but I'm still working with my other one
and I'm just like man my stats are going
to be so my mental health stats yeah I
mean it's like you you already you know
maxed out on one now you're creating
like a subclass i maxed out on penis uh
what's up hey this guy's got a this
guy's got a big dick that's what he's
saying he's got a maxed out [__] anyway
yeah I feel like [__] doing this because
I'm like oh man people must think I'm
legitimately nuts and I'm not yeah
because you don't have you don't have
any you put it all on Dick yeah yeah
exactly